yesterday joe biden announced a 300
billion dollar plan to forgive 10 000
worth of student debt for every debtor
who makes less than 125 grand per year
and 20 000 for every debtor who paid for
college with pell grants now
the whole situation is a little bit
awkward for joe biden because four
months ago his speaker of the house who
was at the time trying to defend biden's
reluctance to forgive the student loans
admitted
that the president doesn't have any
right to forgive student loans
people think that the president of the
united states
is this more on the subject than you
ever want to know will you let me know
people think that the president of the
united states has the power
for debt forgiveness
he does not he can postpone he can delay
but he does not have that power that
would has to be an act of congress
he does not have that power except for
what was that joe oh never mind okay he
has that power it's just like when fauci
flipped on the masks the masks are dumb
the masks are terrible they don't work
stop wearing the oh yeah never mind
they're great and you have to wear them
all the time it's very very awkward when
they have to pivot 180 degrees like that
it's also awkward for biden that the
money will disproportionately help
wealthy white people
as the liberal activist and young turks
commentator nina turner points out the
average white borrower is 12 000
in debt while the average black borrower
is a whopping 52 000
in debt and as the left-wing brookings
institution noted a full third of
student debt is owed by the wealthiest
quintile of households while only eight
percent of student debt is owed by the
bottom quintile but then again this is a
feature not a bug of the plan right now
joe biden is losing support among
college educated whites so very simple
calculation he is buying their votes
before the midterm elections which is
corrupt
sure
but it's also par for the course in
politics especially among democrats
going back to the days of tammany hall
and gangs of new york
the biggest problem with biden's vote
buying scheme is not that it's corrupt
it's not that it's expensive it's not
even that joe biden has no right to do
it
the worst aspect of biden's payoff
is that it is going to encourage more
people to go to college where they will
be treated to a heavily subsidized
four-year training camp to make more
docile and ignorant democrat voters
right now go to goodranchers.com
knowles use code knowles regardless of
what this administration defines as a
recession americans are hurting in their
wallets food and gas prices are higher
than i've ever seen in my lifetime and i
guess really ever in america that's why
i am super grateful for my absolute
favorite meat delivery service good
ranchers good ranchers offers an
inflation proof subscription model that
lets you lock in your price the day you
subscribe plus you can pause your
subscription for up to 90 days or cancel
anytime you want but you will not want
to it's it's just an insane deal
that they are letting you lock in your
price on this incredible quality meet
plus right now they're running a back to
school give back program with the goal
of donating 100 000 high quality meals
to children in need to help them out i'm
offering 10 lucky listeners the chance
to win 30 minutes with me via zoom on
september 30th you can ask me anything
there we're calling it a meet and greet
do you get that do you get it it's a
joke it's funny meet and greet go to
goodranchers.com knowles use code
knowles at checkout you get 30 bucks off
plus free shipping subscribe lock in
your price and inflation proof your
meals for life you'll be automatically
entered to win 30 minutes of meet and
greet with me on september 30th the
offer ends august 31st
goodranchers.com use code knowles at
checkout there is no basis there's no
legal basis there's no real precedent
for joe biden to do this
in
american law and history so he's just
doing it he's just saying okay the
midterm elections are coming up we're
underwater on every single issue people
hate us we're losing a key demographic
let's just pay them off let's just buy
buy their support and if anyone
questions us about it we will just
engage in
what a baptism
what what about what aboutism what about
what about what about and say hey the
republicans they cut taxes so that's
when they cut taxes that's kind of like
us buying the votes of the
college-educated white students
the point
is this
there's plenty of deficit reduction to
pay for the program's cumulative
definition play for the programs many
times over
i will never apologize ever helping
americans working working america's
middle class
especially not to the same folks who
voted for a two trillion dollar tax cut
that mainly benefited the wealthiest
americans and the biggest corporations
that slowed the economy didn't do a lot
for
economic growth and wasn't paid for
and racked up this enormous deficit just
as we've never apologized when the
federal government forgave almost every
single cent
of over 700 billion dollars in loans to
hundreds of thousands of small
businesses across the across america
during the pandemic
no one complained
that those loans caused inflation
a lot of these folks in small businesses
are working in middle class families
they needed help it was the right thing
to do
so the outrage over helping working
people
with student with student loans i think
is just simply wrong dead wrong
so nothing joe biden said there is true
nothing whatsoever but biden said that
the tax cut under trump was only for the
wealthy people it was only for the
gazillionaires and the corporations
that's not true everybody got a tax cut
whatever you think of the trump tax cut
maybe you think it was good policy maybe
you think it was not great policy
everybody who's paying taxes got a tax
cut
under trump unless you lived in blue
states because you couldn't deduct the
state and local taxes from the federal
anymore but that was a politically
genius way to punish the blue states and
i think it was a way to stop the blue
states from free riding on the federal
government anyway that's a separate
point his argument there doesn't really
make sense then he says it it was bad
for the economy it didn't didn't lead to
any kind of growth uh that's well that's
not true at all
listen i wasn't all that long ago but i
seem to remember the trump years being
boom years people were getting richer
people were thriving under trump
economic growth outperformed
expectations it was great enter joe
biden what do we get we get record high
inflation 40-year record high inflation
and we get a recession that's so clear
to people that the only way that joe
biden could deny it was by changing the
definition of recession so that's just
completely made up
and then he went after trump for
giving financial assistance to the the
business owners whose businesses the
government forced to shut down
and then he's saying republicans didn't
warn about inflation neither of those
things are true at the time republicans
said this is a bad idea to shut down the
economy and then to just give money away
willy-nilly
but if you're going to shut down the
economy if you're going to tell people
you can't go to work
you've got to shut down your business
then i think the government has some
obligation
to help you out during that period of
time the government caused that problem
the government mandated that everybody
shut down
the government therefore can't leave
people high and dry
in that circumstance that would be crazy
and furthermore
when when the government comes in and
says hey businesses that we
intentionally destroyed we're going to
give you a little bit of a lifeline to
make it through the next six months or a
year or two years as it turned out to be
that seems to make a lot of sense to me
because you want the businesses to
continue because you want the economy
not to collapse
very different from hey
college students who we didn't make go
to college we didn't force to take out
these kinds of loans who we didn't force
to study underwater basket weaving and
lesbian dance theory and anything else
hey you guys who took out way too much
debt
we're just gonna give you some free
money
which probably will just cause the
schools to raise the the tuition as
they've been doing ever since the
federal government has been underwriting
college education but furthermore which
will just incentivize more people to get
more stupid degrees and not really get
an education but become just docile
democrat voters which is all they're
really after does that seem like the
kind of thing we want to incentivize
that we want to underwrite and do we
really want a situation where america in
america the majority of people do not
get a four-year college degree where
you've got
the country as a whole subsidizing this
degree for a minority of people who
statistically will make more money than
everybody else
does that make a lot of sense doesn't
make a lot of sense to me the problem
with this it's not the corruption of the
payoffs i mean that's a problem
it's not how much money it's going to be
that's a problem
it's that we are incentivizing these
people to go to college i break with my
fellow conservatives on the college
point a lot
sometimes you'll hear conservatives say
college is dumb it's always dumb you
should never go that's not my opinion
sometimes you'll hear conservatives say
this and i hear this one all the time
they say look college is fine if you go
and you major in stem
you know you go and you major in
engineering you go and you study
something that will help you get a job
that makes sense but if you go and study
i don't know history or literature
that's crazy i have exactly the opposite
point of view there is no reason to go
to a four-year liberal arts college to
study a job that's not what the liberal
education is for liberal education i
think is a wonderful thing the point of
liberal education is not to learn a job
it's kind of the opposite
it's to not study anything that directly
relates to a job it's to study the arts
of freedom the arts that allow you to
make sense of your freedom and allow you
to cultivate your higher will and allow
you to suppress and educate yourself and
suppress that those base desires and to
be a free person
to be a free man to cultivate all those
things which you do through literature
which you do through math abstract math
not practical engineering which you do
through the sciences
which you do through literature which
you do through all i think that's
wonderful
my problem with college is not liberal
education my problem with college is
that increasingly it is
pretty much impossible to get a liberal
education on any campus in america
that's not what you get there
instead what you get is leftist
indoctrination
instead what you get is
four years of nonsense
and rather than suppressing your lowest
appetites and cultivating your
irrational will usually you get four
years of misbehaving as anybody anybody
who's been to college recently knows
and then you graduate with a lot of debt
and no education and no practical job
skills and nothing that's the problem
all you really all you really graduate
with is a greater likelihood to vote for
democrats which is the reason that the
the libs are doing this that's why it's
a terrible thing liberal education is
great i wish we could i wish i wish we
had a lot more of it there were probably
a handful maybe half a dozen schools in
america where you can reliably get a
liberal education these days
and now with joe biden underwriting
underwriting four-year college the
problem is only going to get much much
worse
does joe biden have the power to forgive
all this student debt
is that's the question that everyone's
asking joe biden doesn't even have the
power
well what is he claiming is the power
he's saying that
a september 11th law
called the heroes act
gives the education secretary broad
authority to grant relief from student
loan requirements during specific
periods such as a war
or some other kind of military operation
or some kind of national emergency and
for very specific purposes including for
instance to address the financial harms
of a war or a military operation or an
emergency and then joe biden is just
completely perverting the meaning of
this 911 law to say okay well it's an
emergency now
yeah i woke up this morning i felt kind
of like it was an emergency so
we're gonna we're gonna pay off the
student loans of people that i want to
vote for me
that's the heroes act for you
and and then you've got the
conservatives
the feckless conservatives on the other
side crying about how he doesn't have
the real power to do this
newsflash he does have the power to do
this
politicians have the power
to do whatever they can get away with
if you have lived through the last two
and a half years if you have lived
through the reign of dr fauci
and you don't get that i can't help you
you're not gonna make it does does biden
have the right to do this no
he doesn't the law doesn't give him the
right to do this the american tradition
doesn't give him the right to do this
joe biden's creator does not give him
some natural right to do this but does
he have the power yeah of course he does
two different things
this is where sometimes conservatives
and libertarians get a little tripped up
on the way our government works because
they say that's not in the constitution
this legislative body or this president
or this so-and-so doesn't have the right
to do it doesn't have the power to do
that yeah no he doesn't have the right
he does have the power
the way our politics works is that the
the people and the institutions with the
power exercise it
and it doesn't matter what that bill up
on capitol hill and schoolhouse rock
says and it doesn't matter what the
constitution says they're going to wield
that power so joe biden's going to wield
it it helps him politically
he's buying votes okay tail is old as
time
what are we going to do about that
i'm glad you like that clip now look we
have over a million subscribers i want
one quintillion i do and i'm not going
to stop until i get it so ring that bell
subscribe i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]